in 2001 20 years ago this year my
colleagues andrew lang jamie bach and
bill holtz oppel came up with a proposal
for what would later be called bicep
bicep has morphed over the years into
bicep 2 bicep 3 and now bicep array it's
a stunning series of experiments that
unfortunately i'm no longer involved
with if you've read my previous book
a farewell to arms no losing the nobel
prize
i described how i came to
both part ways with and also be inspired
by the continuing developments with the
bicep team recently an analysis was
published in physical review letters one
of the most prestigious uh journals in
all of physics that has the most
stringent limits to date on cosmic
inflation and the observable signature
that might or might not be present from
an early inflationary expansion of the
universe while i'm not involved with the
project anymore i'm fascinated by it and
i want to explain to you the
significance of these results and where
will cosmologists go from here come
along into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
spoiler alert we haven't discovered
anything in this field in terms of
unequivocal proof or evidence for an
inflationary origin of the universe
there's a lot of circumstantial evidence
as we've talked about but there's also
competing models ranging from sir roger
penrose's conformal cyclic cosmology to
paul steinhardt and aegis's bouncing
cosmological models and many more that
we will discuss in future videos
now the question of whether or not the
universe originated in a massive super
luminal expansion known as inflation has
fascinated me personally since the early
2000s when i first came up with the idea
to build a tiny refracting telescope one
that galileo galilei would surely
recognize at the bottom of the world
antarctica specifically the south pole
and over time we made more and more
sensitive upper limits that is we've
excluded an inflationary energy event
above a certain value cosmologists
parameterize the amount of inflationary
gravitational wave energy by what's
known as the tensor to scalar ratio the
symbol is lowercase r
and that is the relative ratio between
so-called gravitational wave or tensor
perturbations and ordinary density or
scalar perturbation
we've been setting limits on these uh on
these effects for over a decade with the
dedicated bicep series of experiments
and this new recent result comes from
the bicep iii incarnation of bicep which
is a massive expansion to anything i
would have ever conceived of back in
2001
this is an instrument that has about a
half a meter diameter aperture and it's
significantly larger almost three times
larger than the original bicep 1
aperture it can cram in many many more
detectors
and couple those detectors with very
very
sensitive phased array type technology
in the original bicep 1 we only had 49
polarized metal machine feed horns that
we used to detect these tiny differences
in the amount of polarization in the
microwave background
but the incarnation of these telescopes
from bicep 1 to bicep 2 which use
transition and superconducting detectors
to the current bicep 3 and now bicep
array series of detectors has been a
slow steady increase not unlike your
iphone
and its evolution from iphone one all
the way up until the current iphone 13.
and back in 2001 we barely had ipods and
it's just stunning to think about how
far the technology has come and these
detectors are made by brilliant
colleague jamie bach at nasa's jet
propulsion laboratory and also supported
via a wide variety of scientists all
over the world and even though as i say
i'm not involved with the bicep 3 and
beyond incarnations i still can't help
but feel a tiny bit of interest vested
interest if you will in the success of
the project
recently we
we heard a great fanfare announced
because of the threshold that was
reached by the bicep 3 experiment this
is
reproduced from the physical review
letters article shown on the screen here
that broke through this barrier it broke
through what's called the an uncertainty
level on the amount of tensor to scalar
ratio the amount of gravitational wave
energy in the early universe produced
presumably by an inflationary event
where the inflaton scalar field had
fluctuations of the space-time metric
that then nucleated waves of gravity
which travel at the speed of light
endure for all time and can make it to
our detectors even today but we choose
to detect them and their presence back
on the surface of last scattering
and that surface of blast scattering is
an imprint a fossil record of how the
universe looked when it was only 380 000
years old so we're kind of putting the
detector system back as close as we can
to the source of the explosion if you
will if you think of inflation as a sort
of type of explosion that ignited the
big bang that we subsequently measure
the results reported by bicep recently
indicate that that we're below the one
percent level of sensitivity the
precision level needed to measure
gravitational waves has broken through
the one percent barrier and even though
the likelihood of the gravitational wave
signature is slightly above a mere uh
two time multiple of that one sigma
result namely the two sigma upper limit
is actually higher than the uh two times
the zero 0.009 are precision level
that's because the likelihood to
slightly shift it over i.e it looks to
the naked eye to the untrained brain as
if there's a slight detection of
gravitational wave energy but there's
not there's not significant enough to
claim detection but the the power and
the procession from uh from the
relatively crude measurements that we
made with bicep one and even other
competing experiments including my own
experiments the polar bear experiment
and other contemporary experiments have
have yet to approach anywhere near this
level of sensitivity now we hope to
proceed even further back in time and
closer to the source of primordial
tensor perturbations if they exist and
remember the stakes could not be higher
because if inflation takes place many of
the most prominent scientists do believe
that the multiverse paradigm is also
ushered into a state of believability
maybe even proof by discovering this and
that we know for sure would be one of
the conclusions because that's what
happened back in 2014 when bicep 2 made
the premature discovery claim that we
had discovered gravitational waves from
the universe's inflationary epoch now
that was retracted later on our
conclusion was retracted we didn't make
a blunder the experiment is exquisitely
sensitive and far more sensitive than
any other experiment ever done of this
type but the interpretation as owing to
a primordial cosmic event rather than
dust in the milky way galaxy had to be
essentially the disconfirmed result so
we weren't able to establish this
conclusively that doesn't mean that
gravitational waves don't exist it
doesn't mean inflation didn't take place
it doesn't mean the multiverse isn't
true
but we would like to have evidence and
so the bicep 3 team has now taken data
from more than just the one frequency we
used in bicep two namely two millimeter
wavelength 150 gigahertz frequency
or with bicep one we had three channels
90 gigahertz 150 gigahertz and 220
gigahertz but those detectors are very
few of those
operating in the diff in the higher
frequency bands now cosmic dust in our
milky way galaxy was the ultimate source
of the large tensor to scalar ratio we
claimed back in 2014 and is the subject
of losing the nobel prize but that uh
that was later found to be uh to be able
to be removed using data from the planck
satellite who were our competitors at
the time and still you know kind of
frenemies and friend now we're not
friend we're not enemies but we do we
did eventually collaborate together to
re uh to reduce the uncertainty uh from
dust and actually show that dust could
contribute the dominant the
preponderance of the signal that we
claim to observe
now what's interesting is that bicep
three is able uh in the very near future
if not now to actually no longer need
ancillary data from another instrument
namely from the planck satellite to go
deeper into the removal process to get
rid of the cosmic schmutz that
contaminates the local galactic
neighborhood the dirty window the dusty
window that we must look through with
our cosmic instruments
so it's fascinating to note that kind of
the gauntlet has been thrown down by
this phenomenal team that continues to
work on a single goal
and although there hasn't been a
detection this is an important proving
ground because what it does is starts to
eliminate
many many classes entire classes of
models of inflationary parameter space
so we're able to really narrow down and
zoom in on the allowable regime in which
these inflationary models could have
taken place
now will we ever be able to rule out
inflation i claim no because even if we
don't ever observe gravitational waves
we could still make the claim that
inflation took place but the energy
scale of inflation was too low to
manifest a observable background of
gravitational radiation that persisted
to this epoch of last scattering so we
can't really falsify that inflation took
place
some say that is a negative for the
inflationary model and and it's
non-comporting with the scientific
method that things should be as karl
popper said falsifiable in order to
constitute good science we've talked
about that a lot i won't go into it
again in more detail there are also
haters of the inflationary theory that
pos because it posits the existence of a
multiverse which some claim is
antithetical to the scientific method
because everything that can possibly
happen does possibly happen and we'll
talk about that in a future video as
well on the physics of free will coming
soon so where are we we've ruled out a
lot of inflationary
models we would need to measure an
inflationary gravitational wave b mode
signal that i've talked about at length
in other videos
in order to conclusively demonstrate the
existence of these gravitational waves
and that would be important because that
would not only help provide evidence for
inflation and maybe even narrow down
even further as much as humans could
ever do narrowing down the
varying parameters that characterize the
inflationary universe it would also
eliminate other contenders for the
cosmic genesis event in other words it
would eliminate things like the
balancing model the expirotic model the
conformal cyclic cosmology of sir roger
penrose the string gas cosmology of
robert brandenburger and cameron baffa
that we'll talk about in other videos on
this channel so this non-detection is
actually an important stepping stone
towards an ultimate measurement perhaps
of the cosmic genesis phenomenon if
indeed it did take place via inflation
and if it didn't we may see surprising
results along the way so these are
really truly heroic results i'm
happy for my former colleagues and
friends on the bicep experiment i wish
them great success and of course with
our small aperture telescopes that we're
building here at uc san diego
at princeton university at uc berkeley
around the simons observatory our small
aperture telescopes these will hopefully
set an important limit or constraint or
detection perhaps of these primordial b
mode polarization signals and i claim
this is my editorial opinion that one
experiment cannot make a definitive
claim anymore we will not be satisfied
in this field of cosmology unless two
different experiments can confirm the
same type of signal they don't have to
measure the exact same thing that's
almost impossible in science they have
to measure broadly broad consistency so
that we can develop a consensus that
inflation took place if again if indeed
it did who knows if it did
but it's quite exciting to note that no
one can really go
uh to the limits themselves no one goes
to stockholm themselves anymore we need
to have confirmation if indeed this
exists and i think that hopefully we
will make great progress again as a
scientist you never want to bias
yourself with the confirmation prejudice
that you are going to detect that which
you set out to detect because it often
leads you to reject things that are
perfectly acceptable but just don't
comport with your philosophical or
scientific worldview so for now this
exciting news released from the bicep
team the bicep 3 team and i'm eagerly
awaiting uh new results to come from
this uh exciting field including results
that will come from hopefully right here
at uc san diego and the simon's
observatory team around the world
you